Diesen Mond dürfte es eigentlich nicht geben!
Die Sprache ist vom 14.
Mond des Planeten Neptun.
Der Winzling “S/2004 N1” hat nur einen
Durchmesser von etwa 34 Kilometern und wurde
bis zu seiner endgültigen Entdeckung vor
sechs Jahren (2013) immer wieder übersehen.
Doch warum existiert er trotz seiner geringen
Größe dauerhaft?!
Experten und Expertinnen ist es tatsächlich
gelungen, mit Hilfe von neuen Analysetechniken
einigen Rätseln zu Neptuns Minimond jetzt
auf die Schliche zu kommen.
Auch den größten?
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos abonniert den Kanal,
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts - herzlich willkommen!
Insgesamt 14 Monde des äußersten Planeten
Neptun sind uns bislang bekannt.
Neptun selbst wurde bereits 1846 aufgespürt
- und nur drei Wochen später dann sein erster
Mond namens “Triton”.
Nach und nach wurden dann sechs weitere Monde
entdeckt, die innerhalb Neptuns Umlaufbahn
kreisen.
Die NASA-Raumsonde Voyager 2 hatte sie bereits
1989 fotografiert.
Aber auch weiter außen gibt es Monde des
Neptuns - und zwar sieben Stück.
Doch erst 2004 gab es erste Hinweise auf den
INNEREN siebten Mond. 2013 gelang es dann
endlich, den 14.
Mond von Neptun endgültig zu entdecken - und
zwar mit Hilfe des Hubble-Weltraumteleskops.
Doch selbst in diesen Aufnahmen kann man diesen
Mond nur als einen unscharfen Punkt erkennen.
Kein Wunder, denn schließlich handelt es
sich hier bei “S/2004 N1” um einen echten
Mini-Mond mit einem Durchmesser von nur 34
Kilometern.
In etwa so groß wie “Ultima Thule” also.
S/2004 N1 liegt etwa 105.400 Kilometer von
seinem Mutterplaneten entfernt; ein Umlauf
braucht 23 Stunden.
Seine Runden dreht der Minimond “nur”
etwa 12.000 Kilometer innerhalb der Umlaufbahn
von Proteus - das ist der zweitgrößte Neptunmond.
Für kosmische Verhältnisse ist das wirklich
eine verschwindend geringe Entfernung.
Das war also wirklich eine große Überraschung,
sagt sein Entdecker, Mark Showalter: “Wir
hätten nicht erwartet, so einen kleinen Mond
so nah neben Neptuns größtem innerem Mond
zu entdecken”.
Lange Zeit wurde der Minimond nur mit seinem
“Katalognummer” S/2004 N1 bezeichnet.
In einer aktuellen Studie in dem renommierten
Wissenschaftsmagazin “Nature” bekommt
er aber jetzt den Namen “Hippocamp” verpasst.
Ein wirklich passender Name, der an die griechische
Mythologie anknüpft.
Konkret nämlich an das Meeresungeheuer Hippocamp,
das vorne einen Pferdekörper hat und hinten
eine Fischflosse.
Und tatsächlich - die Analogie passt: Neptuns
Minimond ist weder Fisch noch Fleisch.
Paradoxerweise ist Hippocamp nämlich eigentlich
zu klein, um eine solch lange Zeit zu existieren.
Schließlich könnte ihn jeder größere Gesteinsschlag
zertrümmern und dem Winzling ein Ende bereiten.
Warum also existiert er dennoch dauerhaft
und wie ist er überhaupt entstanden?
Fragen, die die Fachleute bis heute zu vor
große Rätsel gestellt hatten.
Doch jetzt ist es dem US-Forschungsteam um
Mark Showalter vom kalifornischen SETI-Institut
mit Hilfe von neuen Analyse-Techniken gelungen,
endlich neue Erkenntnisse zu gewinnen.
Hierbei handelt es sich übrigens um genau
dieselben Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler,
die den kleinen Mond des Neptuns 2013 mit
dem Weltraumteleskop “Hubble” auch entdeckt
hatten.
In ihrer aktuellen Studie stellen sie den
Trabanten genauer vor, geben ihm den Namen
“Hippocamp” und äußern zudem auch Vermutungen,
wie er entstanden sein könnte.
Und zwar könnte er sich demnach aus Einschlagtrümmern
gebildet haben.
Und zwar aus Teilen von “Proteus”, dem
zweitgrößten Neptun-Mond.
Wie gesagt zieht “Hippocamp” nur rund
12.000 Kilometer innerhalb von Proteus seine
Bahn.
Und dort befindet sich ein wirklich extrem
großer Einschlagskrater, der 1989 entdeckt
worden war und “Pharos” genannt wird.
Dort heraus ist wohl eine große Anzahl an
Gestein ins All geschleudert worden, was höchstwahrscheinlich
dann für die Bildung von “Hippocamp”
gesorgt hat.
Auf diese Vermutung kommt das Forschungsteam,
weil das Volumen des Minimondes genau den
zwei Prozent der fehlenden Materie im Einschlagskrater
entspricht.
Zudem spricht nicht nur die Nähe der beiden
Trabanten für diese Annahme, sondern auch
die extrem kleine Größe von Hippocamp.
Dazu der verantwortliche Forscher Mark Showalter:
“1989 dachten wir, dass Pharos das Ende
der Geschichte sei.
Mit den Hubble-Daten wissen wir jetzt, dass
ein kleines Stück von Proteus zurückgeblieben
ist, und wir gehen davon aus, dass es sich
dabei um Hippocamp handelt.”
Demnach ist es sogar möglich, dass “Hippocamp”
in den letzten vier Milliarden Jahren bis
zu neun Mal durch Einschläge zerbröselte
- sich dann aber wieder neu aus Bruchstücken
zusammengesetzt hat.
Die neu angewandte Technik ist übrigens ziemlich
clever.
Vereinfacht gesagt hat das Forschungsteam
hier mit unterschiedlichen Belichtungen des
Neptuns-System herum experimentiert.
Acht aufeinanderfolgende fünf-minütige Belichtungen
wurden quasi übereinander gestapelt und entsprechend
angeordnet, sodass die Umlaufbewegung des
Mondes einer genauen Analyse nicht im Weg
stand.
So wurden acht Einzelaufnahmen zu einer 40-Minuten-langen
Gesamtaufnahme.
Experten und Expertinnen sind optimistisch,
dass diese Technik weitere überraschende
Entdeckungen möglich macht - wie beispielsweise
andere kleine Monde, die um riesige Planeten
kreisen.
Wie ist der Mond entstanden?
Auch eine ziemlich spektakuläre Geschichte.
Draufklicken, anschauen und Astro-Comics TV
Abonnieren. würde ich mal sagen.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!